si monsieur le président
madame la première ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues madame la première ministre
nous avons écouté votre déclaration de
politique générale et nous l'avons
écouté très attentivement
non seulement parce que vous avez su
habilement flatter notre patriotisme
sénatoriales mais aussi parce que
rarement un tel exercice sera aussi bien
porté son nom
puisque à la crise géopolitique dont
vous avez parlé la crise encore
sanitaires à la crise sociale et
économique s'ajoute désormais en france
une crise politique une crise civique
est précisément
cette crise politique elle est générale
avec une france en fois de fracturation
et des français envoient de sécession
naturellement ce serait profondément
injuste
de mettre sur le dos des malais macron à
la fois cette fracturation est
cette sécession ce serait tout aussi
injuste de ne pas reconnaître que depuis
cinq ans tout s'est aggravé la
fracturation et la cessation la
fracturation 7 aggravée regardez la
carte électorale de la france lors de ce
précédent vote vous avez là l'image
d'une france en pièces détachées
jamais le vote des français n'ont
autant dépendu
de leurs revenus de leur diplôme de leur
âge de leur territoire un instant vous
vous aviez parlé de l'assignation des
français mais tout se passe comme si les
français est assigné dans leurs
différences
c'est un aveu d'échec et un terrible
paradoxe pour celui qui avait théorisé
la disparition souvenez-vous des
clivages les clivages sont de retour
chers collègues
ils sont de retour
plus radicaux encore dans leurs formes
politiques vous avez vu l'assemblée
nationale
et peut-être plus dangereux lorsqu'il
s'échappe aux catégories politiques
alors madame la première ministre vous
devez et si vous voulez vraiment réparer
ces fractures françaises vous devez
parler aux français comme un seul peuple
plus de français qui ne sont rien plus
deux premiers de cordée
plus de gaulois réfractaires réparer les
fractures françaises d'abord
cette fracturation qui s'est aggravée
et la sécession aussi qui s'est accéléré
elle s'est accélérée à cause de l'an
même temps un en même temps qui n'aura
rien réglé et qui aura tout abîmé
il n'aura rien réglé parce que
de zig zag en tête à queue ce président
virevoltant d'un revirement à l'autre
s'est enfermé dans l'impuissance
et jupiter s'est transformé en gulliver
pris dans les fils de ses propres
contradictions
je voudrais vous en donner un ou deux
exemples vous avez beaucoup parlé des
souverainetés la souveraineté
énergétique
vous avez fermer fessenheim une centrale
nucléaire et va on va ouvrir saint-avold
une centrale au charbon
bien sûr je vous ai entendu et nous nous
opposerons pas à priori contre la
nationalisation d'edf mais vous savez
que ça n'est qu'un moyen et que ça n'est
pas du tout suffisant traiter aussi la
question de la tarification de l'énergie
de l'électricité au niveau européenne
deux grands pays viennent de le faire au
mois de mai tout récemment l'espagne et
le portugal vous avez parlé la
souveraineté alimentaire de l'europe et
on vient d'apprendre qu'il ya un accord
de libre échange avec la nouvelle
zélande qui ne respectent pas en termes
de pesticides les normes que nous
imposons nous à nos agriculteurs
alors ça arrive à coire
[Applaudissements]
madame la première ministre
vous voulez sans avoir pu solliciter la
confiance à l'assemblée nationale mais
vous les retrouvez vous avez raison la
confiance pour les français si vous
souhaitez la retrouver renoncer allant
même temps fait des choix des choix
clairs des choix net une boussole un cap
c'est ce que nous vous demandons d'abord
et ça tombe bien parce que vous l'avez
sous-entendu vous l'avez même un peu
souligné
l'époque a changé radicalement le
président de la république avait parlé
d'un tournant avec le retour du tragique
yoshi le retour du tragique c'est la
guerre en europe mais en économie je
cherche votre ministre mais on levait à
votre place si j'ose dire cet après midi
le retour du tragique en économie c'est
quoi c'est le retour de la réalité ce
sont des taux qui ne sont plus négatifs
ce sont des taux qui sont en train de
s'envoler
l'inflation aussi qui les suit bien sûr
la croissance vous avez dit que la dette
serait remboursée avec la croissance non
parce que la croissance fléchit parce
que la parité entre l'euro et le dollar
est en train là aussi de s'effondrer
renchérissant l'inflation importée bien
évidemment quand il faut abandonner le
en même temps c'est à dire renoncer à la
politique de l'argent facile
qui peut croire qui peut croire ici et
ailleurs pour ceux qui nous écoutent que
demain dans le monde les nations qui
compteront seront celles qui ont dépensé
sans compter qui peut croire un seul
instant que les nations qui ne tiennent
pas leurs comptes tiendront demain le
rang sur la scène internationale bien
évidemment le quoiqu'il en coupe tu
auras et et je le crois terrible pas
seulement parce qu'il aura beaucoup
coûté en centaines de milliards d'euros
à la france
des centaines de milliards d'euros qui
sont sans lien comme l'a dit la cour des
contrats de plusieurs reprises avec la
crise eu copie
ce qui aura le plus coûter dans le quoi
qu'il en coûte
à la france
c'est un changement culturel c'est cette
fausse croyance donner aux français et
vous l'avez dit à l'instant vous avez
parlé de rapports au travail c'est cette
torsion du rapport au travail que le
quoi qu'il en coûte à bouleverser faire
penser laisser penser aux gens aux
français que l'état peut tout
ce qu'il peut pour voir à tous et que
l'amélioration du sort de chacun dépend
in fine et de l'état ce qui est faux
plutôt que sa volonté personnelle plutôt
que des fruits de son travail
c'est ça la grande question madame la
première ministre vous n'obtiendrez rien
de nous rien si vous n'abandonnez pas
ce quoi qu'il en coûte et dès cet été et
dès cet été aidé dans quelques semaines
sur le pouvoir d'achat nous ne
cautionnerons pas de nouvelles des
pentes si elles ne sont pas gagé si
elles sont ça nous ferons des
propositions qui ne sont pas celles ci
voyez mon cher collègue voyez je l'ait
déjà annoncé mais nous ferons des
propositions sur les carburants mais pas
de nouvelles dépenses s'il n'y a pas de
nouvelles économies pas de nouveaux
chèques s'il n'y a pas des mesures
d'encouragement par le travail parce que
notre marque à nous c'est de penser que
le pouvoir d'achat procède d'abord du
travail et non pas de chèques des
chèques sans provision fait par l'état
[Applaudissements]
et d'ailleurs comment pensez vous lutter
contre l'inflation avec une politique
inflationniste avec des dépenses de
l'état qui n'ont d'autres objectifs
finalement que de subventionner des
emplois étrangers sur son taureau une
dépense de l'état vous le savez 62 euros
sont dépensés sur des produits importés
et vont en réalité engraisser l'emploi à
l'étranger en dehors de notre pays c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous voulons des
économies et nous voulons plus de
travail renoncer aux quoi qu'il en coûte
ces réformes est vraiment et vous avez
raison et nous vous suivrons si vous
êtes courageuse pas seulement à la
tribune mais dans les fêtes sur la
réforme des retraites nous vous suivrons
bien sûr parce qu'évidemment il faut
sauver notre régime pas seulement pour
nous mais pour nos enfants pour nos
petits enfants pour cette solidarité
dont souvent j'entends les uns et les
autres rob ashe et le refrain il faut le
faire concrètement et puis évidemment
les réformes des services publics nous
avons trois grands services publics qui
sont en déshérence la santé la sécurité
la justice vous l'avez dit aussi et puis
vous avez l'école ne pensons pas un seul
instant mes chers collègues que la
dépense publique peut tout d'ailleurs si
la dépense publique était la mesure de
l'efficacité des services publics la
mesure de la qualité des services
publics avec 10 points de plus de pipe
par rapport aux partenaires européens
puisque vous avez parlé de l'europe
alors nous serions à l'avant-garde du
bonheur universel bien évidemment et le
ségur de la chanter le ségur de la santé
illustrent ce contresens de façon
spectaculaire
il suffit pas dépenser des milliards
dépensés sans réformer s'est échoué nous
vous ferons des propositions sur
l'hôpital sur les déserts médicaux nous
avons déposé une proposition de loi ne
pensez pas un seul instant que de s'en
remettre aux élus locaux ce sera
suffisant non ça n'est pas possible nous
voulons une sécurité sociale qui soit la
même sur tous les territoires
cette égalité des chances c'est d'abord
l'égalité des chances devant aujourd'hui
un service public de la santé qui est un
service public ap plusieurs vitesses
vous le savez
le quoi qu'il en coûte mais le en même
temps je disais n'aura rien réglé mais
il aura aussi beaucoup abîmé il a abîmé
les idées parce que désormais tout est
interchangeable
parce que désormais on peut passer d'une
conviction à l'autre il aura abîmer les
fidélités
à force de débauchage à force de
trahison
voyez je n'ai pas l'intention et je n'ai
pas non plus la prétention de penser un
seul instant que je détiens la vérité je
crois que cette période et vous avez
souligné l'abstention doit nous inciter
à la modestie à l'humidité
mais j'ai la faiblesse de penser que
l'honneur de la politique madame c'est
la force des convictions
et je pense que al'inverse le déshonneur
de la politique c'est quand on renie ses
engagements c'est quand on trahit ses
convictions eh bien nous ne trahirons
pas et nous ne nous retirons pas il ay
ay si des collègues s'ils ont des
convictions très différentes des miennes
mais ils ont des convictions et je les
respecte profondément parce qu'ils ont
ses convictions là et ce que nous
voulons nous dans la méthode de travail
que vous appelez nouvelle c'est parler
clair et parler clair si vous dire ici
solennellement devant quelques témoins
ce soir et bien que nous ne sommes pas
c'est une confidence macro nist
nous ne sommes pas nous ne deviendrons
pas
nos électeurs ne le sont pas non plus
mais nous sommes patriote nous aimons la
france et nous voulons la réussite de
notre pays
ça signifie que notre ligne sera clair
et sera exigeante
ce sera l'intérêt supérieur du pays et
nous pratiquerons une opposition bien
sûr mais une opposition d'intérêt
général vous l'avez souligné c'est ce
que nous avons l'habitude de faire vous
avez même dit que nous sommes des
précurseurs oui nous sommes des
précurseurs nous avons toujours à mende
et nous avons toujours proposé est bien
souvent les propositions que nous avons
faites sont tombés dans un silence dans
une indifférence parfois même méprisant
je vous avais parlé d'adé conjugale
isation je pourrais vous parler aussi de
laïcité de tant d'autres choses eh bien
ces choses-là oublié ou tomber justement
dans ce silence profond de
l'indifférence de certaines ou de
certains eh bien nous vous les proposons
précisément par l'éclair aussi c'est
aller à l'essentiel l'essentiel si la
france et les français la france qui
doit être gouverné les français qui
doivent être écoutés une france
gouvernée bien sûr que la france elle
est administrée elle est sûre
administrés jusqu à l'absurde east en
simplifier débureaucratiser c'est la clé
de tout ça ne vous coûtera rien ce sera
des économies et ça sera pour les
français une planche d'appel pour
relever tous les défis que vous avez
souligné xi à cette tribune mais si la
france est de moins en moins gouverner
c'est tout simplement parce que la
politique de communication s'est
substituée à la politique tout court
même désormais la diplomatie même les
ormes est cher christian cambon la
diplomatie s'est réduit à n'être qu'une
affaire de propagande politique nous
voulons une france qui soit gouverné
nous voulons des français qu'ils soient
réellement écouter écouter les français
ça signifie revenir aux sources revenir
aux sources ce n'est pas vouloir
inventer des machins et des bidules plus
ou moins participatif qui bien souvent
ne sont des sessions de rattrapage pour
des recalés du suffrage universel
revenir aux sources c'est revenir à la
constitution l'article 3 la souveraineté
nationale appartient au peuple qui
l'exercé par ses représentants
mais aussi par la voie du référendum y a
pas besoin justement de conseil national
de la refondation la france
la france a des institutions pour
réformer l un parlement que 12 vous
devrez respecter en faisant moins
d'ordonnancé et en les gratifiant 80%
d'ordonnancé ne sont plus ratifié c'est
une entorse constitutionnel bien
évidemment mais aussi l un peuple la
france un peuple qui veut être écouté
que de vous de regret consulté beaucoup
plus par la voie de la démocratie
directe sur des grands sujets vous avez
cité l'immigration et la riche et le
champ de l'article 11 nous vous suivrons
ce n'est pas normal qu'aujourd'hui les
français sur des questions aussi
importantes et toujours été laissés à
l'écart de ses délibérations madame la
ministre pour terminer pour conclure
général de gaulle avait l'habitude de
dire que la politique c'est une action
au service d'un idéal vous nous proposez
une majorité de projets ça ne fait pas
un idéal je pense que si la confiance
est aussi bas aujourd'hui c'est parce
que la politique se refuse à viser haut
à viser haut toujours plus haut et bien
et je m'adresse non plus à la première
ministre si vous me le permettez mme
elisabeth board j'ai entendu certains
qui indiquait que
vous aviez un profil trop technocratique
passé politique voulez je vous dis ici
moi je vous dis solennellement que la
politique n'est pas une affaire de
profil que la politique c'est une
affaire de courage ce qu'on attend de
vous ici ce que les français voyez
attendent de vous c'est le courage de
relever la france c'est un courage qui
consiste à dire aux français croyez en
vous même croyez en la france et y est
la fierté d'être français
parce que la france c'est un combat
toujours recommencée qu'entre la
fatalité madame la première ministre à
chaque fois que vous porterez l'intérêt
supérieur du pays
nous serons là nous serons aux côtés de
la république en côte est de la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]